how's it going guys welcome to a i guess
it's
my desk well that laptop i talked about
a long time ago
i figured i'd give an update on it and
reveal
the the setup the desktop i used to have
here um
mobo started having some weird issues so
i got it on the bench
in the other room and i decided to get
this temporary setup going here i just
want to say
i previously complained that windows
wasn't working right on it and it turns
out
it was the the dongle thing
it was actually the problem it was just
flaky
so i trashed it and got a couple of
better ones
uh one really i just got a really basic
usb one that works great
and i've got one that has a more of a
multi-port
so i could get hdmi hooked up and of
course i got the vertical monitor going
and i decided also just go ahead and get
my other laptop going
and just to just have a tv go on play
music that sort of thing
up there it's nice to have
a laptop that can dock and that can like
flip
and be a screen i actually was intending
on hooking up
two screens this actually has two hdmi
ports but it turns out
that my other two hdmi cables are
walmart serta chair which i actually
kind of hate at this point
but uh yeah here's the stuff i know not
the best lighting in the world
this is the hp monitor that i opened a
while back
uh there's a video of it of the unboxing
and setup of everything
but i just wanted a nice vertical
monitor and it's a really cheap monitor
it's only like 100 bucks
so got the keyboard
and mouse
and there it is flipped i'm still
running
mx linux on this thing doing some
programming here trying to figure out
material loading for my game this is
another
more development laptop that i actually
don't use much because
it has some special quadro graphics card
and i just can't get linux on it
very easily i got a few more ideas to
try though and i have hooked up to this
screen for watching stuff and
whatever i've got a little uh thing down
there put my feet up on
and this here is a battery backup
that everything is plugged into was
really more for my desktop
but i'm just going to leave it here
and i'll show you where the old desktop
went
so yeah you have entered my uh obvious
work in progress room
where just all my extra stuff goes and
this is sort of my
bench for anything that's getting
currently worked on
so yeah this is this is my old build
this is what i've been using for years
and years
and i'm just kind of hooked up to a
single monitor here just for a little
demo
purposes and this is an obsidian 250d
case i love this case
everything's actually been pretty great
about this um
but it's been this thing's been flaky
for years but it's been decently
consistent
i got this cheap mini itx motherboard in
here
and i think it's the fail point you
can't really see it too well here
yeah there it is so this motherboard
it seems like as far as i can tell it's
something about these ram slots
because if i reseat the memory it'll
work for several months and then if i
don't know if it gets jarred a little
bit
it'll just like start crashing so
graphics card fits in this little mini
itx case i love it
um i wish i got a bigger cooler this
cooler is
not big enough for my cpu in here so
that's kind of been annoying
i usually have to throttle it down a
little bit just so it doesn't get super
super hot
but at this point if i'm going to switch
out the cooler i'm going to switch out
the motherboard
it's just been acting flaky i'm pretty
sure it's it
i've replaced most of the parts i've
receded most of the parts so confirm
they're good otherwise
so really the only thing left is the
motherboard and it's really hard to
uh troubleshoot intermittent issues
i don't know what i'm going to do with
this thing i might just tear it all down
and build a little linux machine
or something that just runs in this case
because i definitely want to keep this
case i love this case
things you can't even see down there
there's like four hard drives down here
there's a
power supply down there so it's it's got
everything
and uh yeah that's that's what i was
running with three monitors for the
longest time
but now i'm just using that little
laptop
back to the back to the laptop
so yeah this is going to be my setup for
now i'm just going to be programming on
linux
pretty nice machine to put linux on
all right quick little update on the
desk i did get the second monitor hooked
up
so uh that is pretty sweet
um so now uh yeah i'm still using a
little laptop i just have it sitting
back here i know my cable management
it's not the best i don't know if i'm
going to worry about it too much it's
mostly hidden anyway
but uh yeah this is sort of a temporary
setup as you may have guessed by the
cheap walmart table and
oh god yeah those cables look hideous
all right so let's not worry about that
but
um yeah so actually i found out i can
actually have three monitors with this
thing if i leave this one on
it it does uh turn on all three so
that's pretty cool
three monitor sports pretty interesting
especially just through usbc
so that's what this thing is hdmi hdmi i
guess the other cables i was using were
like an old version of hdmi
as far as i could tell so i've got to
get the newer versions
uh to support these newer monitors and
all that cool stuff
so just thought i'd give an update that
that is now the setup
this laptop over here is still just the
same thing it's really just here
to run the tv there's no other reason
for it
so all right well hope you enjoyed this
video
see you guys in the next one don't
forget to like and subscribe
and we'll talk more tech
you